just love having a baby chair here too
like this is like a nice little glimpse
hopefully into our future
and then a little toddler running around
oh god
careful hey guys have you been
i've been good thanks for asking so
today is exciting because we're going to
be having our friends aunt and christina
come over
along with their babies leia and enzo
they're going to be joining us
for just a little get-together because
usually when we hang out it's always at
their house
since they got the pool and like
obviously we would
prefer to hang out over there they've
been wanting to get out of their house
so we're like dude come hang out over
here we get to
enjoy each other's presents at our place
for once
they're heading over right now but the
thing that really sucks
is that the reason why we planned this
for this weekend
was so we can enjoy our brand new
backyard with them
but californiafire said nah you guys
aren't gonna be hanging out outdoors
because the air quality is
literally hazardous right now so we're
not going to be hanging out outside
at least we'll get to still kick it
together we got that going on right now
though i wanted to show you guys
look at this i don't know if you guys
can tell from the
camera itself but can you see
how orange and like yellow the sunlight
is right now it's actually pretty good
right now because these past few days
it's been
bad like really bad where you can't even
see the sunlight because it's just so
foggy and smoggy and ashy and whatever
you want to call it
okay we're not going to be going outside
and if we do go outside we have to wear
a mask
because like i said i looked into the
air quality and it says it's
literally hazardous right now so instead
we're going to be kicking it inside
i think someone's here
hi hi hello friend
oh we missed you hi leia she was so
excited to see you guys
oh cutie okay let's go inside because
this air is toxic look at all this
ash this is crazy
a brand new environment that you've
never been to all right get to leah what
are you doing
leah hello hey girl whoa look at
monkey girl look there's a kitty awesome
you don't have to hold her no more
right yeah baby there's another monkey
over there
look at isaac's baby isaac's baby
it looks so good in here thank you it
feels
good it's before
everything it was when he was helping us
with the putting the bidet
because then shortly after that it was
like oh lockdown time
you can't can't see each other and then
you guys saw when i was doing the stairs
like
from the gate yeah that's when we came
it feels like home
yeah make yourselves at home shoes on
our shoes off
oh i gotta get the alcohol from the car
oh okay
okay i'm a boy hi
dude good morning i wish we could hang
out in the backyard
i know are you looking at it
are you looking at cancer looking at the
camera you're trying to smile
he's like uh i gotta wake up a little
bit more
oh look at leah she's playing with the
cat
he just ran away from like a good two
days like just
lay up be gentle and then like you
gently you want to play with the cat
oh look you have cat you have hello
kitty on your socks oh my gosh
he's almost taller than you now see your
hair
from his headphones from playing video
games dude i can't believe he's almost
your height
that's good though good for you i know
because imagine he was like smaller than
us forever that would be kind of
uh-uh maybe he's almost taller than you
know he's on a sippy toast
you need help do you need help no
thanks i showered today oh yeah do you
want to see the whole place leia
is your first time being here you look
so pretty i like your hair
she's being so shy wavy stride
girlfriend before this when we got into
the car she's like oh auntie
uncle oh yeah like isaac
yeah you knew you were coming now now
you get shy
look at the kitty you want to go up
there follow the cat
oh yeah look let's go check it out
don't hold my hand that's her nothing
up there yeah look up there we
go she's always presenting something now
right there up there come on go ahead
let's go there we go
good job the cat's up there oh this
right there there's the cat his name is
zoe
you want to pet him you have to be
gentle though okay look like this
gentle gentle
do you want to pet them this is your
first time seeing a girl cat
another mirror she's feeling herself i
know she's like oh
cute
he's
yeah
[Music]
oh he went downstairs it's okay we could
play with them later
[Music]
yeah you went down the stairs who is
this isaac's
yeah look let's check out isaac's room
whoa
wow this is such a grown-up
thing now i have leds but
i taped it but then it fell down yeah
they fell down but he
he put it himself he installed this
whole thing on his own nice
yeah and then he picked out all his
computer stuff
turn on your trackpad this is so
different from his last room oh yeah
the little boy bedroom and now this is
like a teenager i know right he's a
tween now this boy
almost a teen waiting for it
leah where are you going girlfriend what
happened what happened
yeah we're thinking about just figuring
out something for here
really blank do you like his room leia
he's playing games right now
[Music]
isaac yeah
here's the other room oh the baby room
maybe one day but currently it's serving
for a science
project for
oh oh my gosh you could really see how
orange the sky is with you guys
so weird right i know the air these days
is just so crazy like the sky
looks so post-apocalyptic oh my gosh oh
yeah
yeah you're still talking about the cat
where's the cat there's another cat
you want to try to find her i bet you
she's behind the red couch
check behind there is she there look
behind the couch
go back there no no let me see
oh she's not here i like all the little
like actors
i just recently like put these out and
they're the photos by the front door too
i recently just put that and then just
yesterday
we and i'll show you in a second but i
ended up putting our wedding photos in
this huge frame and
we want to hang it but casey hasn't hung
it up yet because i'm not the i'm not
good at hanging stuff i hate it
but you want to check out the bedroom
yeah yeah
thanks yeah it's actually really really
similar to our old place
practically the same all we're missing
back there is like the sliding doors to
go to the balcony
but it's like practically the same
layout but yeah look you could really
see how orange it is
i know it's crazy this is the master
bathroom i like how you guys have two
things
oh my god i love it like i never want to
go back
to just having one sink ever again like
ever again
if we had this thing i would be able to
change him on here yeah
super easy this is so convenient just
having like a
ton of counter space i just lay out all
my makeup there and it doesn't feel
crowded what happened do you like it
he's like this is quality mom this is
some quality stuff you're sitting on
some quality
countertop you ready to go down now he's
so big now i know
he's going to be walking soon oh my gosh
are you ready for that
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
you're like
you little boy you're going to be
walking everywhere yeah
pretty soon you're gonna drive both your
parents so crazy
yes yeah oh there she goes she's already
following isaac oh cute
oh you did where was she she's in my bed
oh and then my favorite
the gigantic well for my standards is
gigantic
i'm so jealous of this yeah it's pretty
nice
it's so big too i was like if we really
wanted to we could use this as like a
temporary nursery
another mirror and then look closely
this side look on the other side
what's on this side another mirror
yeah there's one there too
[Music]
she's like i get to look at myself even
more nice
she's exploring i love it how much do
you weigh 90.
what 90 pounds your turn
how much do you wait go go step on it
she's like no
that's scary girl good job leia
great job she went up the stairs wow
[Music]
like what else can i see what else
she's doing now she's like he's over
there
yeah she's presenting the cat that's
right the cat
it's so cute and joe was telling us on
jk news i think yeah he was seeing how
like leia's just presenting you yeah
she's always presenting ryu no that's so
cute
she's like where's the kitty getting
over so they said they wanted a drink
and i want to show tip and you guys what
we've got whoa
this looks fancy what is this
isn't this like really like top-notch
stuff it is and we haven't opened it
omg oh
that is beautiful so pretty and we
thought
who would be the most perfect people to
be drinking oh
that's so sweet we're alcoholics
casey was like we're not gonna get drunk
today but that's why i think she said
we'll see what happens
oh would you bring a whole bottle
that that's that's that's code for
turning up
anything this bottle's not meant to
drink the whole thing out
no you have to savor it in 1942 do you
know how many sips i can do in the night
okay
oh that's awesome oh my gosh i can't
wait to taste it i mean i'm not a huge
like
drinker like this but i can appreciate
the quality
i got a mango michelada
yes i actually had him buy some today so
we actually had two more bags nice
okay and then i didn't forget about
isaac
oh nice and uh because one is never
enough then i brought this too
oh that's awesome what are you saying
there we go oh that's so cool thank you
you guys that's so sweet
welcome they didn't have this at the
market so i brought it
home oh i only have one korean oh that's
so nice you brought it because you were
you're requesting yes we got a lot of
korean meats and
uh some sides and i was like you know
what we're good good go good with this
meal
some korean beer see oh my god
i
these are decent it's still green but
it's getting wrinkly oh yeah
that was way older she would have seen
our lines they were tiny
oh they're right here these are oh my
goodness
they're so dry yeah don't judge the fire
fruit look at the bananas
oh yeah yeah should make some banana
bread with that
we'll use the bad ones first true well
hopefully it's not bitter
it could actually ruin it better as you
drink it let's find out
by trying it now hey let's do it
let me bust out the tahini thing i just
said it my mouth got watery
we're gonna pop that that's what i got
don't swipe that uh
that's no wait don't do that i've never
seen though
yeah those never no no no no no no wait
i think because she's pestering her
maybe or yeah it's very overbearing i've
never seen him act like that
are you okay are you okay she's very
energetic you're okay
right you're good high five yay oh he
did that he went like this
let me see oh what is that oh let me see
yeah
oh the cat you have to be gentle with
the cat okay
uh-oh zoe's on a timeout but you're okay
right
you're good i never what is going on
look at his ears
they're all pulled back oh yeah yeah
let's give him a timeout okay he's on a
timeout time out though
yeah look his tail you want to be gentle
like this yeah gently
okay gentle like this gentleman
what kind of tea are you guys drinking
with this thing here we've never
used it but it's meant for mint tea
because from morocco
wow this is a crazy design i think it's
all handmade too
we should drink the tequila in this
really oh yeah see gentle residential
gentle yeah like this good job
like that gentle a uh gentleman yeah
like this
go like this
look at his hair why is it all up all
right but you guys ready to see the
backyard though
you can see it from here already ignore
the broken window that has been broken
since january
6th why is it broken i mean ugh
okay i remember seeing it from last time
yes
it's still there i know
whoa
dang it's actually raining ash right
here
i thought about i thought about cleaning
it and then just so we can like
chill out here for a little bit and keep
it raining yeah look it actually
it lost the color of the rug it used to
be a lot more vibrant this is
nice you guys like a drink
what do you got what yeah what do you
got oh look yeah you can see our
mini fridge over there oh my gosh this
is crazy
this is all ash that's so cool
right we're in a war zone was this this
wasn't here before
no all this counter space we built out
wow with the same people
yeah yeah and they also did the floor it
was all dirt and stuff before yeah it
was all
dirt yeah crazy it looks so different
yeah
it did in like three three weeks no with
the break was it three weeks yeah i
thought it was a lot
a lot faster no we had like a big break
oh yeah if you include the break
oh so you open it and then there's like
hose back there that's
cool just hides everything so we don't
have to look at hoses
you're hiding hose there's some hose in
this house
oh yeah and then those are drawers them
in
i'm all nosy now no go for it it looks
so different it looks so like
so spacious thanks i know it actually
did do a big difference just by building
things out because then here i'm like
now what do i do here there's so much
space
what do you think leah stepped out here
slept yeah i like to take a nap out here
no oh you have yeah i haven't how is it
it's nice really really nice yeah this
actually it feels like we're
in the indoors the way my dad puts it is
like we just built another kitchen and
another
living room outside yeah yeah that's all
we really did
i like how actually there's these really
big your houses
are blocking the air over here it's kind
of blocking all the smoke
so it's kind of nice yeah that's true
because if it was way more open we'd
probably have a lot more
and we kind of have a wind tunnel effect
too sometimes depending on how the wind
blows oh i see
it does get a gust in here and then we
installed these poles here
so we're gonna actually have these like
string lights
around just in this area right here it's
gonna be string lights
and then i bought some vines like fake
artificial vines and i kind of want to
like drape it on this wall
to just kind of like cover it up you can
even put like a hammock out here whether
it's this corner
or over there true it probably won't fit
over there for our house too like where
can we put a hammer
we have plenty of room for a hammer but
we don't have anywhere to install it
oh yeah we could totally have a hammock
like one of those hammocks that have
their
own face you like the backyard layout it
used to be all dirt
you don't you don't have a before frame
of response
fabulous you're trying to look pretty
for the camera yes
he's like dad i don't have to try what
are you talking about we'll say hi
everybody
hi everybody watching how you doing
she's playing peek-a-boo are you being a
cat
it's a polite way to point his lights up
too yes
hey look i'll turn it on it's really
dim but at night time it makes somewhat
of a difference
ah this is crazy
oh man super dirty and then the
the furniture that we have out front
it's actually like white
i saw that it's not white anymore that's
the first thing i saw was like oh
no yeah it's pretty crazy
[Music]
all right so now we're gonna make these
drinks
with uh mango michelada yeah and a mango
cart oh
i'm gonna try and just put them up in
like one here and one here but we have
the tahini and the
chamoy i don't know how to do this
you're the professional so you gotta
show oh oh
i'm so not the professional the only
qualifications i have is being mexican
that's all i know this is all you i
don't know okay look this is what i was
thinking of doing and i don't know if
this is correct or incorrect but this is
what i was envisioning getting the cup
doing this and then letting go okay
drop that looks pretty good already and
then you go in here
and then kind of do this we're all the
tahini you guys been drinking a lot
no actually i don't even know why it's
gone and then don't know
today is it is it good yeah approved by
the chef
that's amazing because i had him bring
his chamoy because
me being a bad mexican i don't own any
chamois i don't have any in my house
and in fact we have really old lemons
and limes
but the one thing i do have is a tahini
do you think we should put so much moist
in the cup oh
yes my fellow mexican
says yes i'm gonna do it this way a
little bit like that
oh and then you just and then we'll do
this
i don't know it's gonna disappear let's
put the beer in there maybe at least the
beer will have some chamomile flavor
the entire video all you're gonna hear
is just leia giggling it's so cute
i love it i'm just like what is she up
to what is she doing very therapeutic
right it makes me feel younger you know
it's like the fountain of youth is
the audio of youth there to the audio of
you i love it it's so
cute i just love having a baby chair
here too
like this is like a nice little glimpse
hopefully into our future
and then a little toddler running around
oh god
careful what happened where'd he
oh go there he ran away it's okay we
could stay down here okay do you wanna
do you want one of these too yeah but
what would you put in yours
uncle yeah really we should have brought
we should
have root beer oh but he brought you
garritos
oh yeah i thought you knew i know you
forgot
already seen it on purpose okay so um
we're gonna do this one oh yeah i just
mixed in there you'll still taste it
oh yeah no like it's gonna need ice what
do you want to use lemon lime
which old one do you want to use i feel
like we should go in the trash
there we go some ice and beer oh there's
no
let me see what it looks like on the
inside oh my gosh there's like nothing
in there it's not that bad
only two drops just the seeds came out
oh no
voila yay my mouth is so watery i'm so
ready
that's good these things started hurting
do you taste the chamoy
i do tastes really good interesting
having the ice in there but it does make
it colder
right yeah i read the lens another way
i've seen people do these rims
like when they do the salt the salt rim
yeah they just put
some lime on the rim instead of like
chamoy and then
oh my mouth is so watery and then you
just stick it in the in the salt or the
thickening
all right just finished cooking they're
doing pranks over there
me and isaac got the table set
i'm presenting thank you what's up
how you doing your fingers taste really
good all right
finger licking good guys that was clever
[Music]
bartender or do i give the tip a tip to
the bartender
right here yeah it's not like you're
flirting with a bartender
i am i'm behind the bar right now
not bar policy don't get in trouble
oh no oh no enzo you want to say grace
cheers oh i'm glad everyone got a
a a rim it was leah's first cheers yay
we captured it first a lot of firsts
with you today girl
to first in our house to first first
time meeting
first time doing a cheers hi leia from
the future
looking back on your first
that's awesome
[Music]
so happy hi enzo he was flirting with me
right now it was
so cute please jumping hey watch out
where your hands are enzo
what's that right hand doing right there
he's like
powdered this innocent boy is just
trying to eat man
what are we trying to do he's just
looking for some food i'll get big sis
fix this got the potato chips thank you
mama i gave
leia a potato chip she still hasn't
eaten hers yet because she's
feeding everyone else yeah yeah thank
you
thank you oh what's wrong
she hit the table oh no you do not have
child
safe furniture yeah
she did it because um she was trying to
feed me the chip
and then she lost her oh and she kind of
fell into it
what are you doing enzo
my head's too heavy and she's like
cuties
hi my boy hi
[Music]
that's cute tequila and these chips oh
yeah that's what you guys need
oh yeah we just took shots at tequila
here and now we're eating chips
don julio do you guys want another one
are you are you ready for another one i
think i'm done for the night
i'm like it takes time for me to like
calibrate and look into the lens
like where's the camera at where's the
camera you poured me a big one
it was even that doesn't mean it was
small i mean everyone had a big one fair
enough
which uh which makes it even funnier
because if you go check out his vlog if
it's already out
he's talking about how he's gonna tough
it out in his vlogs
two you want me to tough it out yeah i
can tough it up i don't know what's
gonna happen after
we have an extra room we have another
room yep we didn't have an extra
pullout mattress kind of thing someone's
gotta be the dad for these two kids
later then
i could do this you know she's gonna
have a lot i get my practice in
i'll get my practice in whose drink is
that that's yours
[Laughter]
wow and he didn't finish his michelada
she's like y'all are turning up i'm
turning up too she's filming my friend
now
okay you want this why
she has her own drink here but for some
reason she wants this one this one looks
pretty huh
okay so you do want that
all righty who's leaving heading out now
i'm gonna miss you already you guys
spent quite a long time with us did you
have fun leah did you have fun playing
with the cats
did you thank you for this we had we had
a blast
um looking at magnets we had a blast
walking up and down the
stairs like yup these stairs right here
yeah with uncle and
auntie and then we had a blast playing
dizzy we were spinning around and then
we would fall on the floor because we
got so dizzy
and then we had a blast playing with zoe
he's like i don't want to leave
we're playing more oh no on this one
okay okay bye bye
good night hold on a second
hold on there she's so scared
oh my god
no wait no she's all sorts of confused
[Laughter]
time to go home come over again okay
really soon
yeah i already miss you listen okay
say i love you
[Music]
do it again show uncle
she's like no she knows the camera is on
your feet
she's camera shy that's cute enzo had a
blast crawling
all over the place i can't believe
you're still up buddy right he's right
there
he's going to knock out in the car oh
yeah
oh yeah all right good night everybody
good night thanks for having us over
anytime
anytime you guys left a lot of beers
here so you guys got to come back and
help us drink it
no you're going to finish all that no
more next
no no that's not how that works
[Music]
hmm
you